[Applause]
now Westbrook try to put the moon on
heartless as they isolate and twice for
people to hunker down Vincent just make
sure he's that ankle inside to think
three very friendly roll the Williams
had quite a run the other night
[Applause]
the experts or the haters however you
want to put it over the summer saying
like coming off the bench they face his
role and they want him to be more of a
scorer and he needs to do that coming
off the bench yes the foul though they
fell down by as many as 25 fixes and he
gets back on defense getting a two and
hit Westbrook on the drive got the step
on Harold
Beverly on heart had to give it up his
Westbrook this way what a move by
Russell Westbrook for your local gym
tomorrow and try these lay up get a
circus drive by Russell Westbrook why
and again here's the other layup
I want you to try tomorrow and depending
on your age especially go for the pump
sake
make sure you make the player Harnett
and here's Harden squeezing by and
scores shoot 56 over top that moves it
back out
harden late by Beverly Park from deep
yes
hence the three hit one earlier
Westbrook with the rebound and again
accelerates
whisperin way and scores it is so funny
watching him leader one man world Doc
Rivers taking a timeout with four
minutes gone by
third quarter are set on a switch by
zoom BOTS they double up fighting the
open man it's Westbrook for three
yes Russell Westbrook
the log of Austin Rivers on a step-back
it's over George on the step back George
does not go there what a series of moves
by harden to get by George and lost to
Milwaukee and early November the one
loss here at Ben Willis work does it
again from mid-range river's edge we
have three guards
[Applause]
LAN during a first-round pick for the
Sixers last season 26th overall if
Westbrook who's been on fire 25 points
for Kawhi Leonard chased down by house
[Applause]
picks up the personal play by Shannon
[Applause]
that's a step back step back
pump fake three
[Music]
maddis member number six on Beverly come
on
I mean look what do you do as a defender
this is why it goes to the line so many
times while in Tucker with these
stresses are not able to hit the corner
free but they keep it alive
[Applause]